what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to react to stormy
daniels talking about what it was like
to
bang donald trump i don't know why
this video came up on my feed but it did
and i was like hey what the heck
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell um as you guys know i'm trying to
hit 20 000 subscribers and each and
every one of you
helps okay let's jump right into it
[Music]
i laughed at his to his face multiple
times really yeah
i mean my favorite thing to do when he
used to call me was to put him on
speakerphone
with like on set really like my whole
cast crew everybody and i just like oh
god
it it's calling again and everybody
speaker speaker speaker speaker i just
put him on speakerphone and leave
yeah but this is why you can't say that
if you continued to bang him
into the room and just let him mumble
and he would just be rambling about his
wheelings and dealings
yes is that the kind of vibe like if
you're a girl who's spending time with
trump is that he's just gonna constantly
try to convince you how important he is
yes
i mean i could have told you that
without
with just watching his speeches exactly
constantly talking about his
accomplishments that you don't really
care or need to know about exactly
that's interesting
but so it really was as bad as you
described it
sexually it really was just a terrible
extremely
short sort of experience yeah
okay i'm gonna put i don't know why but
i i hate to be this girl i hate but i
gotta
stormy daniels comes off as like a girl
like the way you talk about a guy that
like
screwed you over like clearly he
had sex with you like that because he
didn't like you
and saw you as an object at all yes it
was that bad
it was that bad and let me ask you how
many other bad
experiences have you had in your life
like this bad oh my gosh i've had a
couple
but they okay so the only other two that
like really stick it in my mind is a
scene i did and that me and the guy had
like no chemistry and he couldn't get it
up
and it was just terrible and then he
tried to blame me for it but at least i
was getting paid for that one
yeah i mean that's like a bad down right
because keep in mind i was not paid for
this
right like that's a big misconception i
know you hate that people think that
yes um and then the other really bad one
was this guy
and he was so cute and
i feel bad for him because he was so
awkward
but it was almost the same experience
except for
for whatever reason he when he came
close to orgasm like jumped back
and i was like you're in my mind i
didn't say this out loud i'm not that
horrible of a person he was like um i
was like wait he's coming already like
what
happened and he came over my head onto
the wall onto like a really expensive
piece of art i had
and then he fell off the bed and knocked
a candle off and set my room on fire
how on fire the curtain went up and oh
dear oh dear luckily like
i yanked the curtain down and stomped on
it but um i got
i lost my security deposit on the
apartment because when i stomped on it
like the carpet was charred what a nut
that's amazing it was quite a nut yes it
was
so you're telling me that this guy was
having sex with you and then he got
really far away because he perhaps
knew the force of his own and he knew
that he had to get a ways away because
he didn't want to injure you
that that could be it but then it
actually went it destroyed a picasso
it was not a picasso okay but something
comparable i'd like to imagine it's
something like
millions of dollars no no no okay but
yeah that happened
wow but at least at least he was like
really kind of young and cute i mean i
was young too this was like a long time
ago
so i mean i guess that's kind of the
question like
how many if as a woman if you've gone to
your point in life
have you had a lot of run-ins with micro
penis
oh you know what you want to hear
something crazy not really because most
of the sex i've had
has been in movies so i i know what i'm
getting into
i've never had one night stand really
yeah
that's interesting but what like the
trump thing could have turned into a
one-night stream right
but she's saying it's so awful but you
kept going back
this is actually a debate that i have
with my friends because people are like
yes you did because it was with trump
but
so what defines a one-night stand is it
somebody that you only have sex with
once or
and never speak to again or does it
count if you
only have sex once but you still talk
see i only had sex with him once
but we talked a hundred more times and i
saw him two more times there was just
nothing sexual so is that a one-night
stand or is the actual definition of a
one-night stand did you like never talk
to the person again
i don't know that's a good question yeah
so
because i feel like especially in my old
age that you you sort of like
it almost seems kind of sick to just
have sex with somebody one time and not
keep talking to him after
but people do that all the time yeah but
i don't as an
adult it just wouldn't feel right it
would feel so strange to never text them
again but i've also been a relationship
for like three and a half years so i'm
like kind of
slowly forgetting what it would be like
to actually be single
yeah so if you spent a large percentage
of your life in
relationships yeah you're that kind of
person yeah
and let me ask you does it always get
[ __ ] up because of the porn
no you haven't had that experience i
have
but uh no actually my last relationship
did she still do porn it wasn't even a
thing and i think that's what one of the
things i liked about it so much he never
mentioned it
but he would mention it like um but not
in that context it's not like he was in
denial
but he's the only person that i've ever
been with that it wasn't a thing either
way it wasn't like
cool like i'm taking [ __ ] stormy
daniels like yeah
or like want to meet my porn star friend
like it was never like
cool he just didn't care and it wasn't
it never was
a thing like i never felt like he was
with stormy daniels
really yeah it was awesome is that like
turns out he was [ __ ] crazy
but really that wasn't a thing crazy how
just he shot i think you have to be a
little bit crazy
to do porn if i'm being honest like
there has to be a little bit of a screw
loose
he shot at you no but he would have if
he had a gun i'm sure
really yeah that's good he had a bad
temper damn
and he was crazy you gotta be careful
for that but the porn thing was
something and then the guy
i was up before him that was a probably
our biggest issue and the funny thing is
he did porn with me
really just yeah he just
it got to where he just couldn't handle
it and would like wanted me to quit
i mean it was it was bad he would know
you were at work and he would just be
thinking about some other guy just
drowning yeah makeup off your face was
weiner
pretty much i couldn't handle that and
then when i would come home he was just
a dick for like a week
really yeah wow and and then he was
you know i can't imagine actively doing
porn in a relationship that's gonna be
so
i don't like he was mean to all my
friends that were in the business and i
have a really close friend named michael
vegas who's one of the nicest people
you've ever met
and my ex would be like would just talk
mad [ __ ] about him
hated him and if you hate michael vegas
there's something wrong with your soul
okay yeah cause like okay i know a girl
who is a huge famous porn star
and she like went on vacation with her
boyfriend for a month
the boyfriend had always been cool about
her getting gang banged all this [ __ ] on
camera
but then they come back from the
vacation and he just gets real with her
and he just tells her like yo
like i realized this month that i don't
want you
getting gangbangs anymore well that yeah
that just sounds like his feelings grew
right but but he realized i think in
that time like oh
i'm happier when i don't have to think
about the fact that my girlfriend is
gang bang bang but
bang bang gang bang but then she just
literally was like
i'm sorry like this is a part of me like
this this is more important than you
which i respect so much yeah
you know you respect ah
not for me not for me if a girl told me
that she wanted me to start
stop [ __ ] doing cartwheels or doing
podcasts or whatever you know
yeah so i have a friend that had the
opposite kind of thing
happen really yeah so she um knew this
guy for a long time
casually dated but they weren't serious
he had
like somebody he was more interested
than and she was had somebody she was
interested and then finally they got
together to go on like a real date
and he came back to her house and was
like
so i started talking about how he wanted
to like call a friend over so they could
do
and she was like whoa i don't even and
he's like yeah but you like anal and
she was like i've done two anal scenes
i'm not really that kind of a girl
and he he kind of was like that's
i wanna he's just like you do it for
strangers why don't you do it for me
i see this like and she was the one that
was like i'm the most vanilla person in
my personal life you could ever imagine
like for me it's
it's not like that and he was like i
spent like all these years like waiting
and like planning to finally
and you're gonna take this for me and
she was like what the [ __ ] are you
talking like
so he just assumed that she was gonna be
down for every while
yeah wow yeah and she was like i she's
like i'm not even that crazy on camera
but like my personal life i'm like the
most
like vanilla you could ever imagine i
mean you can't be presumptuous and
assume that just because she does
something on camera that she's going to
want to get into that
yeah but it was like the opposite it's
the guy like saying like hey let's do
i'm going to the the porn convention in
vegas
and it's funny because this is my second
time going but the last time i went
i remember thinking like oh this is
going to be a [ __ ] fest like everybody's
gonna be
banging there's gonna be girls just
talking about threesomes everywhere you
go
really not like that because that's when
the girls are working the hardest
they're literally standing up like 10
hours a day taking pictures with sweaty
no [ __ ] at least when we're on set we
get to lay down
yeah and then you just bend over i mean
like if the girls
don't go out and you see them by like
midnight they already got their makeup
off and they're in sweats and [ __ ]
because they're all tired you know
because their normal work days may be
kind of intense but it's not so long
yeah and it's it's just different you
don't have to be as
i think a lot of it comes from the
mental like where of
um you get tired like with so many
people and you don't know who's coming
up behind you and that
that's where it's that your tent when
you're on set you're among friends and
you're hanging out and
you know do you feel like because i feel
this way to be totally honest like when
you just are meeting like you're doing
meet and greet you're gonna meet 100
people or
never mind more than that there's an
extent to which it's
kind of like like having to meet that
many people is sort of like robbing you
of like your soul of energy that yeah
that you have
it's very hard to have that sort of
superficial level
meeting over and over yeah i get
mentally tired
well it's hard because i get energy from
people but i get energy from people that
i'm like
excited to see and talk to but if i
don't know you how excited can i really
be
not really that excited so um
yeah i understand what they're saying
without it somehow [ __ ] up the part
of your brain that is actually trying to
have like
real communication or real interactions
with people yeah and it's um
it actually does like porn i mean i
think it's
easy to say that having sex with a lot
of people it changes your brain because
your brain gets
used to having like forming one type of
connection
so then forming a different type of
connection is like a new pathway
a lot of the people were totally cool
and respectful and it goes pretty quick
but there's
always like that one or two people that
are just like
and and then there's you can my tour
manager is sitting over there dwayne
he's worked for me for like 11 years and
so he's there is an actual thing the
like he can back me up dwight
last guy last night last show always
right
yeah it's it's without fail the last guy
in the line after the last show on the
last night whether i'm there for a week
or one night
and like but if i'm there like a
thursday friday saturday whatever it's
always the last guy standing in line
at the end of the saturday night that's
just going to be a [ __ ]
in and awkward because he's trying to
leave third weird creepy way or in like
a weird aggressive way it's a
it's always the worst experience of the
entire thing and sometimes they're
sometimes they're just like like weird
like they're nice but they're weird or
it's like some guys
or it's the guy that bites me i'm not
making that up or it's the one who like
what part of your body did he bite i've
been bit in the face
i've been bit on the ass i've had i had
a guy once
duane wasn't with me for this one but
like one of the weirdest things ever
happened was a guy came up to get a
picture
and i went to my mom around him like
this and he just dropped and
licked my armpit
and then took off running oh my god
these dudes are undefeated i was just
like i felt so violated it was so
strange it was so strange but the porn
fans like
it's just certain dudes who
you know they're just trying to eke out
some tiny
little bit of what they want from you
like they know you know that like really
they want to have sex with you but if
they can't get that
i'm just going to lick an armpit
oh my god i can't even just that's weird
i can at least do that
thing i've had happen but it was you
know really yeah oh god
you don't want to know really i really
don't want to know no i don't
think i do i'm nosy i do i don't know do
you want to know i want to know
dwayne's like you don't want to know
everybody i'm jeremy daniels
oh my gosh that was a really interesting
podcast actually um
let me know in the comments what you
guys thought of
that reaction do you guys like these
type of reactions or do you prefer more
of the manosphere content
um also do not forget to subscribe to
the channel you know i'm trying to hit
20
000 subscribers move out of my parents
house bring that notification bell
while you're at it and i am excited to
talk to you guys
next time